I don't think I really to any of my
characters I've played a crack addict
from Boston I played an Upper East Side
princess no I think you know each one is
different it's like asking your favorite
Disney character but I had a pretty fun
cam this year I wore this beautiful blue
Vivienne Westwood gown which felt like
when you're a little girl on you're
playing dress-up or when you go to
Disneyland and you meet the princesses
and get their autograph and then I have
this beautiful rose gold dress for socks
you dress at canvas year which I love in
that the other blue Versace dress which
I didn't realize I looked like frozen
until someone sent me an internet meme
rod Ortega her hair is how I bit my hair
so flawless I do not wake up like this
only Beyonce wakes up like that no this
this this is he is my hair secret
growing up I wasn't
I didn't read fashion magazines or
follow celebrities really
I followed more this home design and
cooking and crafting and you know like
Marc at every Martha Stewart magazine my
love of cooking came from my love of
eating and my mom is an amazing cook and
what I love about cooking is I I noticed
as I was growing up I have there's
there's five of us there four siblings
but that was the thing that always
brought us together that's like
something really really emotional and
symbolic in that you know when you come
together as a family and eat so I really
appreciated the tradition in that
I think that that's the safety in that
is I never play characters that are like
me
the dangerous thing of like being on a
TV show for six years is that people
have seen to the 127 episodes so people
assume and I live in New York I shared
half my wardrobe with my character I you
know dated my co-star who I dated on the
show who then suddenly was my brother on
the show which is a very strange very
strange thing that they they do that's
probably the biggest thing is that
people probably think I'm a lot like
that because that's they've seen the
most of me so so when people really get
to know me or when I make jokes they're
surprised by my dry humor I think I'm
Jason Bateman with my dry humor this is
my job and this is what I do for a chanc
of the year my personal life is also is
not my professional life I have a great
family and that goes into not just my
husband and my daughter but it goes into
my siblings my nieces my nephews my
parents I live a very very normal life
and and then this stuff happens and it's
weird and sensational and exciting and
all of that but it's also you know I
have an understanding that it's not it's
very temporary and fleeting my favorite
moments are the moments where I'm just
with my family and we're relaxing and
it's a beautiful sunny day and we're
eating good food and listening a nice
music and just just having a peaceful
time to do nothing but be together like
that's that's a really that's an epic
nice moment for me